if i do all of this uh my hope is uh
that at the end of the three months uh i
will have made a significant
improvement hi there steve kaufman here
how do we maintain
our commitment in learning a language
that's what i'm going to talk about
today and i'm going to talk about it in
the context
of my next 90 day challenge now remember
if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications
now you know i often make the point that
language learning is not a sprint
it's a long distance race it's not even
a race
it's a journey and there was once a
i think a movie called the loneliness of
the long distance
runner and so as we're engaged
in this long distance process of
learning a language it's easy
to see our enthusiasm flag and that's
why from time to time
i join a challenge at link
and so i'm going to do an idd challenge
but i'm going to do three different
challenges now
there's a place on link where it invites
you to join a challenge
so i joined the with steve
challenge which is where i'm committed
to maintaining my street that i have to
save so many links create so many links
every day
so that's one but i'm also going to do a
90-day challenge in arabic
and persian so it's three challenges but
it's really the same challenge
what i'm committing to do is to save
to create a minimum and i'll go into how
i set these
my goals but 13 links
a day in arabic and 13 links a day
in persian now the streaks
that we track at link have to do with
creating links
but that's not my only activity i'm
going to be speaking with my tutors
two three at least times a week
one tutor in arabic one tutor in persian
i'm going to be doing my usual reading
and listening
however in order to meet my links
target or goal i did a number of things
first of all i adjusted
my daily goal down because i
you know if you go to the settings gear
symbol
uh on link you can set your daily goal
and there's a sort of you know intensive
level which is
i have done in the past which is a
hundred links a day
and then there's what we call casual
which is only 13 links a day
and so i adjusted my goals down to 13
because i want to maintain my streak i
want to be able to do
at least every day i want to do 13 saved
links
in at least one of the two languages so
that means that i have to bring in
new material i have been in both
arabic and persian i have been spending
a lot of time with my
existing content because i have so many
saved links especially in arabic
words that you know i've i've looked up
they're now yellow but i still don't
know them
so i go back into content that i've
listened to before
hoping to move some of these to known
the problem with that is
the brain doesn't remember much it seems
it doesn't remember the words
but it knows that the content is not new
any longer it's heard it before
it's read it before so it's less
stimulating for the brain
so i'm going to force myself to bring in
new content
now this could be in the case of persian
some of the content that sahara is
creating for me in iran about
she travels in her country and this kind
of thing or
about you know she's done some on on uh
movie directors in iran and then she
sends me a link to the movie so
i'm gonna try to see if i can find these
uh iranian movies somewhere it's not
that easy to do and of course the
dialogue is very fast i don't understand
it and
we're trying to figure out how i can
maybe extract the audio and
we're working on that and of course and
with arabic
what i want to do is i want to focus
more on egyptian arabic so that i can
enjoy movies because right now i don't
understand
the movies and most of the movies come
from egypt
and for that reason i've started talking
to muhammad who is from cairo
and we started a few lessons now in
egyptian arabic i have listened to the
many stories
quite a few times in egyptian arabic and
so then i get on with
muhammad and i read a story and then he
and because the stories consist of you
know part a which is
a third person and part b which is first
person or past tense or future tense
and then there are questions with the
answer sort of provided
and so he reads the statement he asks me
a question and i'm reading
along and i answer reading along and he
corrects my pronunciation
and this gets me closer to egyptian
arabic and i'm hoping that through this
process i'll be able to understand
egyptian movies so if i can continue my
sort of input activities reading and
listening
if i can get on with my tutors do some
reading and some speaking
if i can access now movies which is the
live
language people living the language
over a period of three months and but
every day i have to find
at least 13 new words that i save as
links and
put them into my vast collection of
of saved links that i'm still trying to
learn yellow words
if i do all of this my hope is
that at the end of the three months i
will have made a significant
improvement the idea of the challenge
is is is not that you're going to
necessarily measure
how much better you became but it is a
little nudge
to get you going every day because i
want to maintain my streak i want to
save those 13 links
it's a bit of a commitment and i'm
hoping that other people on link will
do the same and so we can compare it
doesn't mean that everyone is studying
arabic and persian
people might be studying chinese or
russian or spanish or portuguese or
whatever it is
english but at least we're kind of
that loneliness of the long distance
runner the loneliness of the language
learner
is lessened to the extent that we can
share
our experience share our activities and
make sure that we maintain our streaks
or
you know whatever level we set for
ourselves goals that we set for
ourselves so we're kind of
collectively pushing each other to work
a little harder
and hopefully enjoy it more because the
goal ultimately is to enjoy
learning the language not necessarily to
i don't know achieve some numerical
number it's to feel more comfortable
more engaged with learning the language
at any rate
that is what i'm going to do for the
next three months it's a 90-day
challenge i'm going to try to maintain
my streak
and i'm going to try to see how far i
can push my
my numbers on my profile at link known
words and so forth
but the only goal i'm going to really
track is the saved links that makes it
easier for me
if fewer you know less pressure
um i'm going to have these increase have
this
increased interaction with my tutors i'm
hoping that that will move me into
a situation where i can enjoy movies
that i have to persuade my wife that
we're going to watch
arabic or persian movies rather than
whatever latest
thing she's found on netflix or amazon
right now we're enjoying
a danish movie by the seaside or
something of that nature
from amazon is spectacular i love
listening to danish
i don't understand it as well as i would
like
i even ran through our mini stories in
danish i see we only have 25
i would love to have the full set of 60
if there's any danish people out there
that want to help us with
getting more content into link please
let me know
and i encourage all of you to make a
commitment
to the next 90 day challenge sign up at
link
thank you for listening